[Musique]
bonjour bonne fin d'après-midi et
bienvenue sur le plateau de qu'est ce
que c'est je vous rappelle qu'il s'agit
d'un jeu au cours duquel il faudra
découvrir une et nîmes
donc la règle est très simple pour cela
on vous projettera dans quelques
instants un petit film d'une dizaine de
minutes au cours duquel vous verrez un
groupe de jeunes gens parler d'un sujet
assez mystérieux d'une manière assez
mystérieuse dans un lieu qui lui n'est
pas mystérieux du tout et ceci pour vous
aider vous suffira ensuite de découvrir
de quoi il parle
je vous rappelle aussi que pour
participer à ce jeu il suffit de nous
écrire émission qu'est ce que c'est
prend 6 rue des alouettes service de la
jeunesse ou rtf et maintenant encore un
petit détail comme d'habitude on gagne
rien jeu là on ne partait pas on gagne
quand même le plaisir de jouer ensemble
alors à tout à l'heure moteur
[Musique]